au sommaire ce soir la disparition de la
comédienne denise grey à l'âge de 99 ans
le voyage de jean louis debré en corse
le ministre de l'intérieur qui a ouvert
le dialogue avec les nationalistes se
heurte au désenchantement de nombreux
élus la visite éclair de bill clinton en
bosnie et le portrait du probable
vainqueur du dakar 96 pierre lartigue
madame monsieur bonsoir la gentil grand
mère un peu fofolle de sophie marceau
nous acquitter de nigré est décédé
aujourd'hui à l'âge de 99 ans la doyenne
des comédiens français avait pris sa
retraite de la scène il ya tout juste
cinq ans après avoir joué une dernière
fois le rôle de la vieille tante in
extravagante dans une pièce de robert
lamoureux la soupière aux machines et
françoise david
entrée en scène et recevoir l'hommage du
public
c'était pour cette très vieille dame
toujours jeunes comme une respiration
royal plus facile ou mater bon deux
doigts comme ceux ci allaient bouge tous
les placer son extrémité votre langue
vous aussi votre lourde en arrière
jusqu'à ce que vos lèvres touche la
première pas l'ange michel et l'élève et
vous souple et denise grey pour l'état
civil edwards in n'imaginait
certainement pas quelle fille de
modestes immigrés italiens traversera le
siècle sous les feux de la rampe
certificat d'études en poche elle
devient figurant aux folies bergères et
c'est yvonne printemps qui la pousse à
faire du théâtre
françois périer et le dire que parce qu
ils donneront notamment la réplique
elle sera aussi la grand mère dont
rêvent les adolescentes dans la bouche
de claude pinoteau la première fois que
j'ai dit ici c'était en vain courant
vaincu une d'ailleurs tu t'en fous je
fais comme toi
ouvrez les yeux grands comme ça paul
poiret tu sais qui c'est
couturier pas jamais sant yann le fils
naturel de ne le rendre médicis et et
dort sur un site web utiles
merci servent le vrai du directeur de la
famille lui a supprimé le corps se
maintient mais jamais porté
denise grève et pendant toute sa
carrière sauter de loges en loge et au
gré des tournées transporter sa bonne
humeur et sa joie de vivre dans toute la
france et pour arsenic et vieilles
dentelles place à la famille sa fille
est l'une de ses arrière petites filles
l'accompagner sur scène après jour du
monde hier toute la profession vedette
hommage à son talent et à sa vitalité et
les deux modes madeleine renaud et
denise grey échanges et peut-être des
confidences sur leur fontaine de
jouvence commune le théâtre j'aime la
vie ça m'embête beaucoup le voient que
la porte arrive et qu'il va falloir la
la passe et c'est très désagréable mais
enfin où je tiens à en profiter le plus
possible jusqu'au bout
elle rêvait d'être centenaire et tous
ceux qui tous les 16 septembre c'était
dignement la doyenne du théâtre français
l'espère bien aussi mais elle a cette
fois manqué son rendez vous
une explosion probablement due au gaz
s'est produite en début de soirée dans
un immeuble de douze étages dans un
immeuble la périphérie de reims il y
aurait une vingtaine de blessés dont
certains grièvement atteints
nous aurons sans doute d'autres
informations avant la fin de ce journal
la préfecture des alpes-maritimes a levé
en milieu de journée la cellule de crise
mise en place d'hier matin à la suite
des fortes pluies qui se sont abattues
ces derniers jours sur la côte d'azur
ce soir la décrue est générale mais les
dégâts sont très importants
reportage yannick à rossi diane richard
la siagne de retour dans son lit avec
l'arrêt des précipitations et après midi
la décrue a été plus rapide que prévu
partout le fleuve est passé c'est le
même spectre concours on déblaie on
nettoie solidarité entre voisins devant
l'adversité cette dame de 82 ans avait
quitté sa maison il ya deux jours elle a
pu constater ce matin
l'étendue des dégâts c'est une pâte et
d'avant-hier mon petit fils allait me
chercher ma part j'ai ma fille ce matin
dans la zone artisanale tout proche les
pompiers et l'armée sont à pied d'oeuvre
le ballet des experts d'assurances a
déjà commencé matériel détruit perte
d'exploitation pour la majorité des
sinistrés
l'avenir est très incertain ça va être
dur parce que tu n'as pas fait 7 jours
vers mars quatre ans à penser bon on va
essayer pas tant les assurances ont
atteint les expertises pégomas paie un
lourd tribut à la colère de la siagne
pourtant des études d'aménagement du
fleuve existent mais les travaux sont
trop coûteux il est évident que nous
pourrions un seul supporter les frais de
réelles de réaménagement et
d'endiguement glacial
les communes ont jusqu'à mardi pour
demander leur classement en zone
sinistrée
ce soir la situation est redevenue
normale la cellule de crise a été levée
la station de ski d'isola 2000 est de
nouveau accessible
le risque d'avalanche est diminuée pour
sa première visite officielle dans une
corse dont il affirme avoir compris le
désarroi sans précédent le ministre de
l'intérieur jean louis debré a tenté
hier et aujourd'hui de renouer le fil du
dialogue avec les élus locaux mais aussi
les militants nationalistes
alors que les attentats se sont
multipliés ces dernières semaines sur
place pour france 2 michèle fines disent
ils en choeur
ce commerçant est un homme content mais
lucide
en corse les négociations avec le
ministre ont suscité autant de
scepticisme que d'espoir que venue des
ministres pour toujours dit que je
rejoue
ça veut dire qu'elle n'a eu beaucoup
quand même ça fait plusieurs fois qu'ils
viennent n'a jamais trouvé de solution
donc cette fois ce sont les trouverons
et les solutions parce que les promesses
en a marre on aspire un peu avoir un peu
de paix et de tranquillité cfoot n'a
fait en corse à la paix avant voilà
voilà
ils demandent que ça hein depuis ce
matin dans les salons de la préfecture
jean louis debré négocié la paix
monsieur le ministre consulte
l'un après l'autre les représentants des
groupes à l'assemblée de corse défilent
cet après midi c'était au tour des
nationaliste jean-guy talamoni est ici
leurs représentants il ne cache pas sa
satisfaction
s'il n'y avait pas un rapport de force
politique entre la corse et la france eh
bien peut-être que les dialogues aurait
eu beaucoup plus de difficultés à sur ce
nouveau aujourd'hui si le flnc a
contribué par la campagne militaire qui
l'a engagé puis par sa déclaration
récente si les féliciter chaque pape
contribué à ce que chez dialogue
s'instaure et bien il aura fait quelque
chose de profitable à l'ensemble de
notre pays et c'est sur cette photo de
famille que s'est achevée la visite en
corse de jean louis debré mardi c'est le
premier ministre en personne qui recevra
à paris les élus de l'hymne les
conditions d'une négociation sont posées
mais tout reste encore à faire
encore ce l'année 95 a été celle de tous
les records avec 602 attentats perpétrés
contre 379 seulement dire et on en 94
l'autre nuit dans le maquis le fnlc
canal historique a ouvertement défié les
autorités de l'état républicain en
rassemblant plusieurs centaines de
militants surarmés en fait depuis vingt
ans tous les gouvernements successifs
ont multiplié les tergiversations d'
amnistie en répression
la carotte alternant avec le bâton
bellery fourni il y a vingt ans la
première action violente du mouvement
nationaliste
un commando de la rc action pour la
renaissance de la corse dirigée par
edmond simeoni retient de six otages
deux gendarmes seront tués lors de
l'assaut et le mouvement dissous
cinq jours plus tard le flnc né le 4 mai
76 par une première
bleu c'est l'indépendance de la corse
qu'ils réclament en plastiquant des
édifices publics des banques ou des
agences de voyages le flnc s'en prend
même au plus haut symbole de l'état
avery 80 l'avion du président valéry
giscard d'estaing se pose à ajaccio deux
minutes plus tard une bombe explose à
mort et huit blessés
avec l'arrivée au pouvoir de françois
mitterrand première trêve des attentats
premiers espoirs des nationalistes
malgré l'octroi la corse d'un statut
particulier en 82 les indépendantistes
s'estiment floués fin de la trêve le 19
août la corse connaît la plus violente
nuit bleue de son histoire et pierre
mauroy dissous le flnc six mois plus
tard de répression en discussion d'une
majorité à l'autre paris sans faire dans
la question corse
c'est l'époque où le flnc consacre
l'assassinât politique comme pratique
courante dans la clandestinité depuis
sept ans le flnc éclatant 90 d'un côté
les terroristes officiellement repenti
du mpf mouvement pour
l'autodétermination dirigée par alain
orsoni avec son bras armé le flnc canal
habituel de l'autre la con coltat
nationaliste la tendance dure avec le
flnc canal historique comme branche
armée
si le canal habituel annonce 191 un gel
total des actions militaires le canal
historique lui refuse toute négociation
avec paris les attentats continuent
entre désaccords politiques et dérives
mafieuses
arrive l'heure en mai 95 la vendetta
après le meurtre de stéphane gallo du
flnc canal historique 95 une année avec
près d'un attentat par jour une
quarantaine de meurtre dont 12
assassinats de militants nationalistes 6
dans chaque camp et une réconciliation
qui paraît difficile
si l'on en croit un sondage ifop publié
demain par le journal du dimanche
françois mitterrand a été pour 43% des
français le meilleur président de la
vème république devant sans charles de
gaulle 38%
valéry giscard d'estaing 8% et georges
pompidou 7%
deux jours après les obsèques de
françois mitterrand sa ville natale de
jarnac en charente est en train de se
transformer en lieu de pèlerinage
la municipalité souhaite acheter la
maison où l'ancien président a vu le
jour pour en faire un musée
le cimetière continue de recevoir l'avis
de nombreux admirateurs mais aussi de
simples curieux
reportage françois privat pascal tous et
non les roses s'amoncellent devant le
tombeau de françois mitterrand
malgré le froid des anonymes et
seulement des anonymes
entre dix et quinze mille sont venus se
recueillir aujourd'hui dans le petit
cimetière de jarnac entre sincérité et
curiosité je pense qu'on peut dire ce
qu'on pense
je suis pas curieux je suis mieux pour
lui
pour lui rendre sa dernière visée voit
la photo souvenir
message personnel on parle à voix basse
et avec retenue de françois mitterrand
l'homme et ses idées au delà des combats
et des divergences politiques françois
mitterrand étaient quelques uns des
traits aînés d'être est destiné et
peut-être pas uniquement sur le pro
politique faut pas croire que les gens
très attachés pas si demain des autobus
en provenance de château chinon sont
attendus en charente le cimetière des
grand'maisons devient un lieu de
pèlerinage comme il le fait chaque année
depuis le début de sa carrière politique
provinciale jacques chirac s'est rendu à
tulle pour présenter ses voeux aux
corréziens
l'occasion pour le président de la
république de faire allusion à son
changement de statut le destin at il dit
à signaux êtres un parcours
et aussi des devoirs véronique sainte
odile jacques chirac n'a pas laissé
passer l'occasion l'élu a présenté comme
il le fait depuis 25 ans ses voeux aux
corréziens
le président de la république a montré
cette fusion en exemple comme la
réussite d'une évolution et des
difficultés surmontées
c'est une leçon d'histoire de france que
l'on reçoit pas l'histoire officielle
bien sûr mais l'histoire authentique du
peuple français qui depuis la nuit des
temps
traces c'est sion avec deux aspirations
également légitime le souci de la
permanence et le désir de l'innovation
la france traverse une période
turbulente de sa longue histoire est la
surmontait mille épreuves elle
surmontera celle que l'évolution de la
société et aussi du monde nous impose
jacques chirac croit aux vertus du
terrain et de l' écoute pour restaurer
la confiance
alors dans les semaines qui viennent le
chef de l'état reprendra son bâton de
pèlerin pour essayer de faire renaître
en france l'optimisme et l'espoir de
lendemains plus ensoleillé bill clinton
effectué aujourd'hui un bref déplacement
en bosnie le président américain qui a
renoncé à se rendre à sarajevo pour at
il expliqué ne pas aggraver la situation
étalé sur la base de tuzla à la
rencontre des gi's de la force de
maintien de la paix de l'otan pour leur
remonter le moral
gilles rabin en attendant clinton look
et en hongrie par le brouillard ont fait
répéter la troupe l'accueil doit être à
la hauteur de la mission des boys en
bosnie après plusieurs heures d'attentes
le président américain est enfin là il
vient expliquer aux soldats des états
unis pourquoi une pataugent dans la boue
des balkans dans cette boutique ils
comprennent mal que vous avez envoyé mon
mari à tuzla m'a dit ce matin la femme
du connais pas je suppose monsieur le
président que vous accepterez et lui
apporter son cadeau d'anniversaire
le procédé est digne d'une campagne
électorale c'est normal clinton est en
campagne électorale
pour les présidentielle américaine de
novembre prochain vinton n'est pas aller
à sarajevo comme l'espérait des
bosniaques
les bosniaques et leur président leur a
dit azad [ __ ] sont venus à clinton à
tuzla entrevue sobre accueille moins
sobre en croatie mais l'escale à zagreb
était prévu de longue date et l'accueil
a pu être organisée au portugal près de
neuf millions d'électeurs sont appelés
aux urnes demain dimanche pour la
cinquième élection présidentielle depuis
la révolution des oeillets qui a mis fin
en avril 114 un demi siècle de dictature
salazariste deux candidats seulement
postule au remplacement du socialiste
mario soares un candidat de gauche et un
de centre droit une campagne qui n'a pas
suscité de réels affrontements bel
exemple de consensus l'expo 98 une
exposition océanographique qui mobilise
d'ores et déjà tout le portugal
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
isabelle bechler marie richard
sinon on prend cette publicité l'avenir
du monde se joue dans les océans
c'est bien ce que le portugal veut
prouver en mobilisant toute imagination
et la technologie dont il est capable
aux mouvements de commémorer sa
découverte des ânes voilà cinq siècles
le portugal veut transformer ce pas ces
valeureux en modernisant sa connaissance
des océans
il attend plus de 100 pays participants
pour montrer au monde les acquis de sa
marche forcée vers l'europe une nouvelle
prospérité que le portugal qu'on
souhaite encore largement sur ses liens
avec son ex empire colonial
ces ouvriers africains trop souvent
exploités en sont la preuve
les personnes là d'états d'âme nous
sommes au milieu d'une campagne
présidentielle assez active et tous les
candidats sont absolument coïncidence si
roy publie sur le support de
l'exposition donc nous n'avons pas pour
le moment aucun problème politique
la chaussée des géants de l'expo 98 un
des projets phares du pays à son prix
humain les ouvriers immigrés qu'on
néglige bien sûr de mettre en vitrine
qui n'ont pas et de loin les garanties
sociales du reste de l'europe à
commencer par les salaires la plupart
d'entre eux doivent se contenter de
bidonvilles ou des squats comme cette
invraisemblable cité de queen ka de
manchots abandonné par son constructeur
à la révolution des oeillets aujourd'hui
1500 familles il subsiste immigrés
d'afrique et portugais confondues fatima
el ville depuis 20 ans déjà beaucoup de
gens de la campagne qui finissent ici la
vie est de plus en plus difficile pour
les paysans vous savez les africains
c'est pareil ils ont la vie dure là bas
alors ils viennent ici mais c'est pas
mieux
pas d'eau courante bien sûr des
installations électriques sauvages
forcément dangereuses et une précarité
absolue pour 4000 personnes de plus en
un an que l'arrêté d'expulsion a été
publié
alors personne ici n'a beaucoup d'espoir
dans l'élection présidentielle a juste
soit un président c'est au procès comme
des noms pour le droit ou non pour la
bouche le sort des laissés pour toutes
de la modernisation portugaise va peser
dans les urnes demain
c'est pour cela surtout que le candidat
de bush devrait l'emporter
on a appris aujourd'hui seulement cette
triste nouvelle le doyen des français
s'est éteint le 29 décembre dans un
hôpital de grenoble et 1000e fourcade
était dans sa 112e année né à tlemcen en
algérie en juillet 1884 emile fourcade
avait été inspecteur des contributions à
sidi bel abbès où il avait épousé en
1915 rosalie qui demeurera sa compagne
durant 62 ans le doyen des français
était à la retraite depuis 1940
depuis plus de 55 ans christophe lambert
lui est en pleine activité il vient de
monter entre autres une société de
restauration baptisé bonne ap l'acteur a
également investi une partie de ses
économies dans une entreprise près de
roanne qui fabrique de la cuisine sous
vide avec l'espoir non dissimulée de
conquérir le marché américain
reportage sébastien guibert josé
boulesteix charlène et stéphanie sont un
peu le trac leurs parents aussi
normal ils ont tous rendez vous avec le
patron un patron qui l'ont déjà vu à
moitié nue faire tarzan au bout d'une
liane
mais ça c'était du cinéma dans la vraie
vie les secrétaires de l'entreprise le
trouve charmant gentil c'est pas mon
genre de gars font non il est bien quand
même
désormais christophe lambert veut
devenir la star mondiale de l'agronomie
sword
visiblement il est aussi à l'aise pour
décapiter les méchants que pour tripoter
des terrils une terrine de l'europe et
ça ça c'est une terrine de pâté de foie
gras
c'est quoi ça sert et la communication
facile c'est vrai que ça fait plaisir
j'ai mangé avec lui ce soir alors que il
pourra puis je pense qu'il doit être
fatigué de ce que toute l'entreprise se
retrouve donc dans un trois étoiles
temple de la cuisine bien de chine point
newman et sylvester stallone entre
autres se sont déjà lancés dans la
gastronomie
mes paroles de vedette avec christophe
lambert c'est autre chose
gérard depardieu fait son vin moi je
suis plus intéressé par une technologie
de pointe que par quelque chose qu'en
fin de compte beaucoup de gens peuvent
fait il ya ya ya plein de choses que
j'aime j'ai une passion pour la peinture
ça veut pas dire que je peux mais je
n'achète pas des tableaux en me disant
ah oui celui-là il va se vendre bien
j'achète pas tableau parce que ça me
communiquent quelque chose c'est la même
chose est lé sous vide ça communique
quelque chose
le cinéma et le sous-vide de carrière de
success story à laquelle ses employés
sont prêts à quoi il s'appelle le
goûteur madère et c'est un bourreau
dalphond comme dirait le regretté
fernand raynaud sur la piste de kiss
bull luc alphand a en effet été battu de
12 petits centièmes de seconde par le
skieur autrichien
deux fois vainqueur en 95 de cette
descente prestigieuse le skieur de
serre-chevalier aurait bien aimé
réaliser le même exploit que le suisse
franz heinzer vainqueur trois fois de
suite sur place thierry clopeau alain
poirier même quand ils ne gagnent pas
luc alphand entre ici à kitzbuehl au
panthéon des meilleurs skieurs mondiaux
à l'arrivée ce matin luc hessel verrière
au par les deux plus grands skieurs
autrichiens d'histoire 40 et toni sailer
tous les deux plusieurs fois vainqueurs
zanetti crème
elles font même s'il n'a pas gagné ce
matin il a fait le bonheur de tous les
supporters venus par centaines
et pourtant parti avec le dossard vite
l'udc vainqueur deux fois déjà l'an
dernier sur cette pente du hanau cam a
bien cru tenir une troisième victoire
d'affilée ce qui aurait été historique
les 900 intermédiaire ce n'est qu'une
toute petite faute dans le dernier des
verts avant le schuss d'arrivée qui lui
a coûté la première place mais je crois
que deuxième ici une belle course j'ai
essayé je sais que j'ai le potentiel de
les gagner et pour tous s'en tienne
c'est un autrichien qui l'emporté on
n'attendait le champion olympique ortiz
c'est finalement son compatriote gunther
madère 31 ans tient du monde d'accord en
remportant la première descente de sa
longue carrière football avec le début
des match de 32e de finale de la coupe
de france à cet après midi auxerre a
battu lyon 1 à 0 but signé et christophe
cocard donc permet à l'équipe de guy
roux 2
franchir
c'était obstacles et d'arriver en 16e de
finale l'exploit de ces 32e de finale a
été réalisé par le club de bléneau qui
évolue en nationale 3 et qui a éliminé
l'équipe de bastia en première division
d'autre part à signaler que le club de
valenciennes midi hier en liquidation
judiciaire a bénéficié d'un sursis pour
pouvoir disputer ce soir sa rencontre de
coupe de france face à strasbourg
gilbert duclos-lassalle raccroche
définitivement son vélo c'est
aujourd'hui sur le vélodrome de roubaix
qu'il a choisi de faire ses adieux à la
piste à 41 ans le double vainqueur de
paris roubaix a effectué un ultime tour
de roue sur les pavés du nord entourés
de deux mille cyclistes et non des
moindres reportage marianne mars 2009 il
avoue être du béarn ou si c'est presque
un enfant du pays
ces derniers tours de roues c'est au
vélodrome de roubaix qu'il a choisi les
données heureux de retrouver beaucoup
d'amis heureux de revenir sur un endroit
mythique et certainement les plus grands
souvenirs de gilbert duclos lassalle et
de sa carrière sur ce vélodrome et je
crois que cela brommat ont fait
désormais je dirais m'a fait perdre
étape du tour mémoire en d2 grand
bonheur c'est d'avoir gagné de probant
louis duclos lassalle furax
c'était l'an dernier lui qui nous avait
plutôt habitués à ces sourires le
victoire en 92 et 93
aujourd'hui on la jouait plutôt sur
l'air de la balade 20 kilomètres et
quelques pavés pour des dizaines de
petites reines en seuls les copains les
pros et tous les anonymes venus faire la
fête et du club ça nous fait plaisir
puisqu'il nous rejoint donc nous on lui
souhaite bienvenue au club des retraites
c'est vraiment le dernier des vieux
combattant pour qui était au moment où
j'étais dans la compétition bon c'est
que c'est comme ça la vie
malheureusement échos savoir étage
aujourd'hui pas de sprint à l'arrivée du
vélodrome et le geste symbolique de
raccrocher son vélo au clou sous l'oeil
attendri de la relève c'est une grande
émotion surtout que c'est aujourd'hui
qu'ils arrêtent vraiment fait carrière
c'est sans jubilé je suis très heureux
pour lui parce que ça lui a fait très
très plaisir marqué de toute ma vie
là encore le papy gâteau sera pas prêt
de dix enfants je crois que c'est la
bande de robbie le dakar 96 se termine
demain dimanche sur les plages de la
capitale sénégalaise chez les motards
victoire probable sauf accident de
l'italien est dit orioli sur yamaha dans
la catégorie autos c'est le français
pierre lartigue sur citroën qui devrait
franchir la ligne en vainqueur pour la
troisième année consécutive pour
préciser leurs enfants avec bonnet et
figure sur le dakar il ya parfois des
tornades surgi de nulle part
c'est un phénomène naturel sur le dakar
il ya des pilotes qui ne font pas
l'effet d'une tornade
et c'est aussi un phénomène naturel
pierre lartigue est de ceux là
lartigue le méconnu l'article discret
mais lartigue
comme vous le voyez sur ces images un
bon vivant ou du volant et qui ne se
prend pas au sérieux
en tout cas il va vite et il ne cache
jamais il est le seul dans ce cas
sur le dakar
certains pilotes conduisent un peu
entente y donc c'est peut-être pour ça
qu'ils pratiquent leur voiture et qu'il
a une petite bague parce qu'autrement on
est dix pilotes à pouvoir gagner le
dakar on est tous la même valeur en
pilotage mais après bye à la différence
de sentir le terrain puis il ya
peut-être aussi le coût du petit renard
du le renard de mostaganem c'est son
surnom atyrau lartigue il est en effet
né dans ce village algérien il ya 46 ans
et c'est peut-être pour ça que l'afrique
il sait la dompter lartigue personnage
humble qui a vu son père mourir sous ses
yeux pendant la guerre d'algérie est un
pilote un peu à part pas de charisme peu
de panache mais trois dakar dans la
poche et une foule de qualité
essentielle pour un rallye raid
j'ai fait quelques zéros navigation
comme tout le monde sur ce rallye il ne
finira jamais ça vous met pas de
pression supplémentaire est au contraire
ils vont maudit pour mettre sur le bon
chemin et il répond ce n'est pas grave
va y arriver
fait extraordinaire de plus alors
l'ennemi intime de carla artigues c'est
ari vatanen le finlandais volant et sa
fierté c'est de l'avoir bête une
nouvelle fois une sorte de revanche
qu'ils ne voudraient pas avoué est aussi
la démonstration que sur un dakar c'est
bien l'endurance et la sagesse qui prime
comme dans une fable bien connu mais où
la tortue serait remplacé par le fameux
renard de mostaganem
notre grand spécialiste des bijoux de
famille marie-josée le picard nous
propose maintenant un petit tour au
salon bijour cas le salon du bijou
fantaisie et vous allez le constater sur
ces images de filles qui ont choisi il y
en a pour tous les goûts et toutes les
imaginations le lit je sais du décor du
cinéma ça bouge ça brille ça arrête la
tension est taquine le regard pendants
d'oreilles géant de l'eau la spolier de
pêche miraculeuse de carl ausy au salon
vise leur cas on joue de tous les
violons avec des bijoux fantaisie on
regarde les doigts on remarque les
cheveux quand les épingles doré de
matières premières scintille un fil de
fer chénard alexandrins rang de boules
de bronze chez afrique on ne voit que la
tâche du coup et le dessin des lèvres
colliers ou sacs miniature le tempo
idéal à bijoux c'est un souvenir ça
rappelle des voyages et sa sortie à une
garde-robe chez ombre pour l'ordre une
collection de coeur un terreau sombre un
amour limpide passion simple ou
sentiments compliqués pour des
collectionneuses des petites sorcières
qui s'accrochent les lézards les grigris
de chez mali qui épingle les papillons
des hannetons des sites web ni bigeon
c'est la grande ville pour un soir
hollywood collection c'est le top du top
la copie des vagues de rita hayworth de
greta garbo d'ingrid bergman magnifique
c'est la bague que porte et rita
hayworth à la route c'est la bague de
rita hayworth dans le film salomé qui
sonne chez bach sait pas trop s'il enfin
le point de mode de la saison sera la
couleur pâte de verre de vaud locke
couleur claire d'aquarelles collier
ceinture guirlandes de fleurs de
feuillages et de fruits
et dans notre grande série des
informaticiens ont encore frappé
voici la terre à vision comme son nom
l'indiqué ce système révolutionnaire va
vous permettre très bientôt de voyager
grâce aux satellites et à des caméras au
sol de faire en quelque sorte le tour du
monde en 80 secondes un nouveau procédé
mis au point actuellement par deutsche
telekom et expérimenté sur berlin
reporte à jean-claude allanic
jean-françois je vais visiter la terre
du bout des doigts c'est le geste qui va
peut-être demain bouleversé notre vision
du monde une nouvelle voie ouverte sur
les autoroutes de l'information par des
informaticiens allemand en faisant
tourner le globe je fais tourner l'image
en question
ensuite j'ai ici ce qui peut s'assimiler
à un manche à balai d'avion et qui va me
permettre de zoomer par exemple je le
fais ici sur la région de tokyo
mais pour l'instant c'est sur
l'allemagne que la démonstration la plus
spectaculaire voici l'europe et la
france avec le manteau neigeux des alpes
un mélange d'image de satellites et
d'image de synthèse et regardez bien la
descente vertigineuse sur berlin zoom de
la caméra sur la place centrale jusqu'à
la limite de son point de résolution
c'est ensuite une autre caméra installée
sur un immeuble qui prend le relais je
me le confirme ceci n'est pas un trucage
su bien en ce moment même alors que le
système de télévision est en train de
découvrir le centre de berlin au pied de
la célèbre église cassé comme
l'appellent les berlinois et vous pouvez
le constater on peut même lire l'heure à
l'horloge
après berlin c'est tokyo que l'on
découvre avec le fuji yama qui sera
équipé de caméras au sol un système
relié au monde entier qui ouvre des
perspectives sans limite
on va pouvoir aller dans une université
ce que les questions une caméra y
assister en direct à un cours en train
de se tenir
on va pouvoir visiter son lieu de
vacances entrer dans un hôtel regardez
sachant des révisions
être opérationnel dans deux ans et ce
sera sans doute comme pour internet
une nouvelle révolution planétaire cette
dernière information pour être tout à
fait complet
un indien vient de décider de mettre en
vente pour 200 mille dollars ses ongles
pour la bonne et simple raison qu'ils
lui rendent la vie impossible il faut
dire que ce brave homme à des ongles qui
dépasse le maître l'ongle de son pouce
mesure très précisément 1 m 30 de gens
communs qui risque de ne pas faire
fortune
demain midi n'oubliez pas votre
rendez-vous et que polémique l'émission
de michèle cotta consacrée aux dossiers
corses en direct d'ajaccio dans un
instant la météo d'isabel martinez avec
un dimanche plutôt ensoleillé le dicton
du jour à la saint-yves est jeu taillé
une bavette à la buvette 1 à demain 13h
après le bêtisier du samedi et les
enfants de la télé
le dernier journal vers 12h50 en
compagnie de florence dauchez florence
qui reviendra sur la triste nouvelle que
nous avons appris cet après-midi la
disparition à l'âge de 99 ans de la
comédienne denise grey